let's go to Louis from New Brunswick
Louis from New Brunswick welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
Louis from New Brunswick I see that
you've muted yourself if you unmute
yourself we'll be able to talk so sorry
that was uh
that was my mistake there you go um
thanks for having me David great great
to be here love your show pleasure
um about a month ago about 20 retired
intelligence professionals penned a
letter to the Wall Street Journal
stating that in their opinion
the hunter Biden lifetime story bore all
the Hallmark signs of a Russian uh psyop
operation
yeah and in fact I believe it was 51.
did how what number did you say 20. I'm
reading that it was 51 former Intel
officials oh okay yeah you're right I
was just guessing uh based on my uh you
know full of memory but you're right 51.
and then um then I remember you covered
the story a while ago of this strange
origin story of how Madison Catherine
got married yeah you know some Russian
woman came over to the U.S and like a
fake uh uh fitness competition
yeah
my question to you Dave is do you think
that Russian intelligence services are
much more uh ingrained in our society
that we uh that that we like accept or
consider so I think Russian intelligence
is much more infiltrated in the United
States than the average person is aware
of I think our intelligence agencies
know the degree to which it's the case
but yeah I think that there are all
sorts of ways in which the average
American isn't aware but it's not just
Russia I think it's important to mention
there's lots of countries whose
intelligence services are very ingrained
and very slick but Russia is certainly
one of them
in your opinion do you think it's
possible that uh the Donald the
political Donald Trump that we are aware
of in the current sense is in fact a
product of this sort of infiltration no
I don't have any evidence for that I
think you know we have to be really
careful because next thing you know the
right Wingers will be saying oh you you
thought there was going to be video of
trump and Putin planning stuff I think
Trump is sort of a useful idiot for a
lot of different movements and people
and it's very clear from what we know
that Russian intelligence took an
interest in Trump decades ago to some
degree as they take an interest in many
American Business people it's not unique
to Trump but over time they clearly
realize Trump is kind of a doofus and
his ego and his narcissism maybe make
him a more interesting Ally in some
sense and at the end of the day we know
Russia had a preference for Trump over
Hillary in 2016 doesn't mean Trump's an
agent or a spy or anything like that
he's just kind kind of a useful idiot
that's the reality
okay I guess that's comforting in a
sense to hear yeah I mean we don't have
to go more conspiratorial than the facts
point to but to say there's nothing
there I mean listen he was doing he was
being invited to Russia decades ago
Russia was casually cultivating him at
the way they do many uh and they had a
preference for Trump over Hillary that
we can say with certainty
okay got an economic question for you if
you have time sure
so I got into a lively conversation with
a couple buddies at work some uh you
know all over the political spectrum and
I was I was wondering if you feel like
uh Social Security is a socialistic
program as opposed to you know looking
at the Spectrum the political Spectrum
economic spectrum as opposed to like a
fascistic uh policy okay and I was
here's the issue with these terms all
right okay in some very general sense
any time you collect money
for a program through taxation and then
distribute the money
in some narrowly defined way you can
argue it is in a sense socialistic in
practice what we're talking about here
are capitalist economies with social
welfare programs where the vast majority
of the money you make at most incomes
you get to keep
some slice of it goes to programs and
there is some redistribution there there
is certainly there are certainly folks
who get more than they put in and vice
versa that doesn't mean that it is a
socialist country or economy we might
just be saying there are certain areas
where we want to use the collective good
for the betterment of society and it
becomes almost semantic when people say
is it socialistic well maybe what do you
mean by that but these are programs that
every social democracy which are
capitalist countries have and it makes
what what we call it kind of irrelevant
interesting well yeah because I felt
like I feel like in a universal a
universal human uh uh response of
disgustes towards
um hypocrisy it doesn't matter like what
religion what Creed you know everybody
is usually offended by hypocrisy yeah so
if this person was uh saying like it's
very very right on the on the Spectrum
and was looking forward to receiving
Social Security and I was like well it's
funny because that you're so excited
about that because I consider something
like that and also unemployment
insurance
socialistic policies yeah I don't think
they're socialistic I think they're just
social safety nets that come that are
put in place in capitalist societies and
by the way I mean you pay into Social
Security so it makes sense that you
should get money out in that in that
sense that's nothing like socialism
by their definition so the these
semantic discussions in my mind really
miss the point Louis
interesting David it's been a pleasure
talking to you today the pleasure has
been all on this side of the microphone
Louis thank you
all right there goes Louie thank you to
everyone that called in that does it for
today we will take a break and we will
take calls again if I have anything to
say about it